Hi, YouTube. It's Ed Miliband, the Secretary
of State for Energy and Climate Change in
the United Kingdom.
I don't think that the environment should
or will lose out to ah-the economy in the
coming year but only if we take the right
decisions. Obviously, what's hapeping in the
economy is at the top of people's minds at
the moment, and we have to show people that
tackling climate change as the world has pledged
to do this year culminating in Copenhagen
in December 2009. And fixing our economy,
creating the jobs of the future are not inconsistent.
They are consistent. And that's why it's so
important that President Obama has talked
about the green stimulus as part of his overall
economic stimulus ah-package. Ah-ah and I
think it's very important why across countries
we need to be talking about ah-that sort of
action.
But I think the other thing I would say is
that I recognize that governments alone can't
ensure that we meet our obligations to the
climate in 2009. It needs people as well.
That's why we need an international movement
which goes across countries, telling politiicians
like me ah-that we need to reach a global
deal in copenhagen in 2009. That's why we
need to involve business. I've been talking
to business here at Davos about that and how
we involve them in that process. That's why
we need faith groups. That's why we need people
across societyof all persuasions to be saying,
"Look, the climate is too urgent a problem.
And we know that the longer we wait, the higher
the cost." The climate is too urgent a problem
to leave. And that way we can ensure that
the environment doesn't lose out to the economy
in 2009.